hey guys today i want to show you a very
very simple very quick way to increase
the performance of your windows machine
a lot of people have already done videos
on this but i'm just going to do my own
it's going to be a very very quick
simple tutorial this one you watch in hd
it's how to increase the performance of
windows vista using virtual memory
so open the start uh the start menu and
right click on your computer
and select properties
from here
we're going to select advanced system
settings if you're using windows xp
there's going to be an advanced tab
you select that and in here there's a
performance section
and hit the settings button on the
performance section
again hit the event tab
and here you'll see virtual memory this
is the paging file on your hard disk
it's the it's basically the area on your
hard disk that windows uses as if it
were ram
uh this helps if you have maybe a 7200
rpm hard drive like i do and it's
relatively fast so hit the change button
and a good rule of thumb is to use
approximately one and a half times the
amount of
ram you have for your virtual memory
so i have four gigs of ram so i selected
six um
gigabytes of virtual memory you hit
custom size
and you hit
and you enter the amount in megabytes as
you can see here that you want
to use as your virtual memory when
you're done hit set it should show up
here okay
okay
and okay
and your computer's done
that's just a really quick way for you
to increase the performance of windows
vista using virtual memory so
thanks for watching subscribe peace